educational facilities on the 3rd of
December minister lavrov will address
the meeting he will talk about the
sustainable development until 2030 it
will be implemented together with the UN
program aiming to develop volunteering
as an activity and promoted on December
the 6th minister lavrov Base in Milano
we're expecting an open and mutual
respectful dialogue at a high political
level on the matters of European
security the common challenges and
prospects of cooperation of the OSE
Member States we're expecting that the
discussions will make it their
contribution to the reducing tensions in
the euro-atlantic and the fight against
the transnational threats as well as
provide an impulse to the settlement of
conflicts in the current issues of
humanitarian cooperation the Russian
priorities in the meeting in Milano will
include the fight against terrorism the
drug threat the linking of integration
processes in the fight against terrorism
and the drug threat all rather
integrating the processes and the
protection of traditional interests in
the fight against terrorism and the drug
threat which are the central topics on
the agenda we're also expecting to have
a talk about the continuing expansion of
the NATO military infrastructure and the
Alliance's movement towards the Russian
borders under the pretext of aggressive
anti Russian propaganda Russia will also
draw attention to the violations of
language and educational rights of
citizens the oppression of the freedom
of the media the growth of neo-nazis and
ethnic and confessional tensions which
have seen in Ukraine as well as the
United States in the countries of the
European Union especially the Baltic
states we're expecting to support the
OSE efforts in the conflict settlement
including context in the east of Ukraine
Transnistria nagorno-karabakh it's
working the Balkans and the
co-chairmanship in the Geneva
discussions on stability in the
Transcaucasia Russia along with its
allies has prepared full draft projects
or fight against terrorism and on the
role of OSE in the fight against drugs
on freedom of access of the media to
information and protection of language
and educational rights of national
minorities we're expecting they they
will be confirmed by the OSC ministers
over all over 20 draft documents are on
the discussion and our experts take part
in this work and on the sidelines of the
OSC Ministerial Council we're also
expecting bilateral meetings between the
Russian Foreign Minister and his
counterparts heads of Foreign Ministries
of other states of the OSCE and of
course he will have meeting with the
authorities of the organization itself
as well as other international
structures let us move on to another
urgent topic the development of the
situation around Maria butanna we are
deeply concerned by the new change of
the detention regime for the Russian
citizen Maria butanna who was arrested
in the United States last summer on
fabricated claims she is qualified by us
as a political prisoner all of these
restrictions imply full isolation for 22
hours a day so for 22 out of 24 hours a
day Maria butanna stays in absolute
isolation she's not allowed to leave the
cell
make phone calls or be in general rooms
she can only do this in night time and
only for two hours
this of course negatively affects her
health not only due to the individual
features this could affect the health of
anyone at the same time she does not
receive qualified medical aid our
diplomats on the 27th of November had a
visit to Maria butanna we expressed our
resolute protest to the prison
authorities and demanded the day stop
such abuses also we sent a note to the
u.s. Department of State with a serious
protest on this occasion we qualify the
US authorities actions as a means of
pressuring Maria bhutanam before the 19
December expected court hearing on the
case inspired against her of course we
will continue demanding the liberation
of the Russian citizen who is a victim
of absolute Tyranny rebooting is not
just a political prisoner today we can
say that she is a hostage of the US
authorities she's held hostage by the
authorities of the United States of
America to only one go to manipulate and
reach their political agenda now moving
on to the situation in Syria's you know
on the 28th and 29th of November Astana
hosted the eleventh international
meeting of hi representatives for Syria
apart from the delegations of the Syrian
government led by the Syrian permanent
representative at the UN and the
opposition left by the tumor and the
guarantor countries Russia Turkey in
Iran it also included the observers
meaning the special envoy of the UN
secretary-general mr. de Mistura and the
delegation of Jordan representatives of
the International Red Cross committee
the office of the High Commissioner for
Refugees overall we are positive on the
results of this meeting its participants
discussed a wide range of Syrians
settlement issues from the political
process including the continued work to
finish the creation of the
constitutional committee in accordance
with the decisions of the Syrian
National Dialogue Congress in Sochi up
to the plans to hold an international
conference for supporting the
repatriation of Syrian refugees also the
sixth session of the work group for
liberation of the detained persons the
transfer of bodies and search-and-rescue
operations was held on the sidelines of
the meeting the efforts in this format
have started bearing tangible results on
the 24th of November with the assistance
of the Russian military in Syria in the
city of Alba in the north of Aleppo
province the first exchange of ten
Syrian citizens for 10 fighters of the
armed opposition from the governmental
prisons was held we expect such
exchanges to be continued and become a
wide-scale the agreements reached during
the meeting in the capital of Kazakhstan
are seen in a joint declaration of the
guarantor countries of the Astana
process as you know it has already been
published the most serious attention was
paid to the situation on the ground in
particular in Eid Lib in spite of the
efforts taken by Turkey within the
implementation of the Russian Turkish
memorandum of the 17th of September this
year the situation remains very
dangerous the terrorists are doing
everything they can to undermine the
measures to create the demilitarized
zones and to separate them from the
moderate forces the scales of their
provocations keeps growing on the 24th
of November the nusra fighters carried
out a mine shelling of the neighborhoods
of Aleppo using chlorine projectiles
injuring over 100 people or rather over
100 people poisoned with chemicals
these hundred people also include
children the Syrian Foreign Ministry has
sent letters to the UN secretary-general
the chair of the UN Security Council as
well as the Director General of the OPCW
we once again call an international
community to react to this barbaric
attack we've been warning for a long
time that the terrorist innately power
were preparing chemical false flag
attacks including the involvement of the
white helmets previously they carried
out such work to provoke the us-led
coalition to provide massive attacks and
shellings of the government forces now
their goal as we think is different to
undermine the implementation of the
Russian Turkish memorandum and to
undermine the cooperation in the asuna
format in particular between Russia and
Turkey
another element meeting on Syria in
Astana has shown that the efforts and
the plants of the terrorists are futile
the guarantor countries as said in the
text of their joint declaration
resolutely condemned the use of chemical
weapons in Syria and demanded carrying
out investigations by the OPCW as the
main international competent and
relevant Authority establishing the
facts of the use of chemical weapons
these investigations should be timely
and professional in full compliance with
the Chemical Weapons Convention we
regret to note that the United States of
America which is an observer of the
Astana format refrained from sending
their representative to the eleventh
international meeting it seems that our
American partners have their own agenda
in Syria and they are not concerned by
the efforts of the peaceful political
settlement in this country and of course
this is shown by the u.s. activities in
the transit rate here
which cause a Syrian concern in Russia
and other countries in fact the US
military has assumed the role of the
safety and security umbrella based on
the separatist Kurdish activists to
establish a cozy state in the northeast
of Syria last week they continued
establishing American I emphasize
American observation posts along the
Syrian Turkish border in the localities
of Talib yot and in Al Arab in kobani it
is hard to imagine how such steps
coincide with the adherence to unity
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity of Syria which had been
numerously reaffirmed by the United
States of America in international
bilateral documents adopted by
Washington we do not even talk about the
adherence to international law now let
us move on to the you do Ukraine the
Kiev Authority continued playing with
fire recently they were homina rather
approved the imposition of martial law
in ten regions of the country the events
were carefully planned the first step
was a provocation by the Ukrainian armed
forces around the Church Street all the
evaluations of these events already
given by the Russian authorities the
plan of the Kiev regime and of course
the president poroshenko is apparent
first of all it is aimed at using the
martial law to raise his own electoral
rating which continues plummeting this
is also an attempt to gain political
points on the wave of another ruse a
phobic sentiment under the pretext of
countering the alleged Russian
aggression serious limitations are
implied in the main constitutional
freedoms of the Ukrainian citizens
including a ban on the freedom of speech
freedom of assembly movement now the
Kiev authorities if they wanted to could
revoke anything
their population from personal
belongings to their documents and papers
these are the authorities that the
authorities have granted themselves with
the Ukrainian law enforces have
exclusive Authority up to the use of
force without any rulings and decisions
which is a serious threat in itself of
the growth of civil conflict in the
integrity of the Ukrainian territory
we've also taken note of the fact that
martial law is selective in nature and
concerns mostly russian-speaking regions
which in the vast majority according to
the polls do not approve of the
activities of the current Kiev
authorities we consider the events in
Ukraine as another signal that the
situation in the country is getting more
confrontational we call on the UN OSCE
Council of Europe and other
international organizations to take note
of this threat of unleashing a forced
scenario the human rights situation in
Ukraine is concerning we warn their
Western protectors of the high dangers
of this idea of president poroshenko who
in his desperate attempt to save the
country involves the country into
another risky action which could have a
serious and grave consequences for
Ukraine and European security this story
that had stricken the world community
history of the alleged murder of
journalist Bob Janko which had been
fully planned by the Ukrainian law and
forces and the Security Service was
planned and carried out and even reached
the UN Security Council as a complete
fake later we saw that the journalist
was safe and sound and the life these
are exactly the same methods perhaps the
same people planned these provocation
provocation isn't is the main
characteristic of the actions of the
Kiev regime they do not have any other
opportunity to affect the situation
there's no dynamic in economic
development not a single positive
stabbing the integration of the civil
society and bringing back the unity no
opportunity to implement any of the
Minsk agreements and of course they have
nothing to come up to the elections
apparently when we talk about the
attempts to for re-election promises are
not enough real results of the
implementation of the first term
promises are required but nothing has
been done that's why this operation was
required this is a provocation with
far-fetched consequences I think in this
hunt for personal ratings and personal
political survival in the attempt to
stay afloat in any circumstances the
main thing was forgotten the country and
its people by the way speaking about
another provocation of Ukraine as you
might remember around six months ago a
Ukrainian delegation in the United
Nations how the fake event and not
surprisingly it was held in the
framework of the Ukraine led forum for
the fight against fake news this topic
was declared as a forum or workshop on
the fight against fakes which and the
event itself turned out to be fake
because Ukrainian diplomats tried to
qualify it as part of the session of the
Committee of the UN General Assembly on
information in fact it had nothing to do
with the committee session
moreover as we had told you those who
came to the forum wearing camouflage
uniforms including snipers or standing
in the corridors of the organization and
threatened Russian diplomats with
physical executions surrounded them and
so on this matter was stated to the
Secretariat of the organization and we
have received the results of the
investigation the official response says
that of the Deputy Secretary General of
the UN summarizes the results of the six
months of the investigation of the
Ukrainian actions during the forty
session of the UN Committee on
information in a beginning of May this
year let me remind you that Ukraine had
organized these false and fake events
supposedly on the sidelines of the
committee and the participants were
represented as snipers of the
anti-terrorist organization so the
response in the form of a note not just
some piece of paper an official UN
document so it says that the guests of
the Ukrainian event were not authorized
to be present on the second floor of the
headquarters which has additional
limitations for visitors in particular
requiring them to be accompanied by
accredited delegates from the inviting
mission at the same time it was
established that let me remind you that
the Russian delegation and the Russian
mission to the UN demanded that they
analyze the CCTV materials in the
Secretariat because we immediately heard
from Ukrainians that we were doing this
information that we were wrong but we
counted that we had the materials and
the facts so based on the work of the UN
it was established that the Ukrainians
who had threatening our diplomats were
not accompanied by the Ukrainian
diplomats and we are glad that the UN
traitor it has finished the
investigation of this incident had
admitted the fact of violations made by
the Ukrainian delegation and these
violations are this is diplomatic speak
if we use the real facts we see that
they simply falsified the events that
took place in the UN we believe that in
the context of promoting peace and
international cooperation it is
unacceptable to use the UN as a platform
for political provocations and any
violations inside the organization's
should be prevented immediately
especially by those who for who this has
become the norm in the light of the
constant violations of rights and rules
and I would like to say that today we
will publish additional materials on
this topic we will remind you how
Ukraine in particular the Ukrainian
foreign ministry declared that this was
not true and the Russian Foreign
Ministry was speaking things that won't
not real we have the results of the
investigation provocations are the style
of the current Ukrainian authorities
moving on to other topics we've taken
note of the messages published in Afghan
amia media these statements of the
Council of the Afghanistan president for
national security mr. mohei upon the
second session of the Moscow format of
the consultations on Afghanistan that
took place on the 9th of November in
particular he said that Russia allegedly
doubts the sovereignty of Afghanistan
and Afghanistan itself was present at
the meeting as a guest kind of quote
Russia in cooperation with the regional
partners takes coherence taps in
promoting the relaunching of the inter
intra Afghan settlement the session of
the Moscow format including Afghanistan
China Pakistan Iran India Kazakhstan
turkeys the Tajikistan Uzbekistan
Turkmenistan and the United States
according to the general estimation of
the participants was an important step
in establishing direct dialogue on peace
between trouble and the Taliban movement
we note that the president of
Afghanistan has on numerous occasions
declared he is the readiness for
peaceful negotiations with Taliban in
any place and at any time he was the one
who initiated the participation of the
delegation of the Supreme Council of
peace in the Moscow format as a
representative of the political forces
of the country our country as an
organizer provided the Kabul delegation
with equal rights with other
participants including by providing the
right to give a first speech to the
representative of the Supreme Peace
Council we would like to remind you once
again that Russia provides a platform
for dialogue between the opposing sides
of Afghanistan we do not try to replace
them add the negotiations we are ready
to continue cooperating with Kabul in
establishing peace and turning
Afghanistan into an independent peaceful
and self-sufficient country free of
terrorists and drug crime and if the
representatives of the Afghanistan
authorities doubt questions the
sovereignty of this country I think that
they should look for answers elsewhere
not on the territory of the Russian
Federation I suggest that they have a
look at another continent we've received
a question Pakistani TV channel asking
to comment on the recent terrorist
attacks in Pakistan including an
explosion at the Shia mosque America
region and the attack on the Consulate
General of China in Karachi the
responsibility assumed allegedly by the
separatist group baluchistan Liberation
Army moreover Pakistani journalists
wanted to know the Russian view on the
messages
that the leader of the Buddhist and
liberation army who has been living in
London for a long time has received
political asylum in Britain I would like
to clarify the Russian position our
answer on the terrorist attacks is
apparent Russia resolutely can then sell
any terrorist attacks that cannot be
justified we had previously expressed
our attitude to the extremist attacks in
neuroscience Russia by supporting the
relevant declaration of the UN Security
Council as for the aforementioned leader
of the separatist group mr. Murray we do
not have information on his current
status in the United Kingdom and on his
place and role in the hierarchy of the
villages town liberation army neither
can I tell you anything about his
involvement and the group's involvement
in the events in Karachi this issue at
least in the part related to the status
of Britain should be addressed to the
British authorities also during the
previous meetings we've heard the
Russian position on the reform of the UN
Security Council I would like to pay
more attention to this issue since it
was already stated in this whole you
know that Russia supports reforming the
UN Security Council to make it more
representative and more reflective of
the current geopolitical reality this
position is well known at the same time
due to the significant differences in
the approaches of the UN member states
we should continue pursuing such a model
of reform that could be supported by the
majority of the Member States much more
than two-thirds of the vote formerly
required in accordance with the UN
Charter ideally this should be a consent
it is important for the talks to be as
transparent and white as possible
involving all the offers without
establishing any deadlines and of course
one of the key moments we cannot allow
the efforts to provide the council with
more representative nature to affect its
efficiency and effectiveness no matter
how the reform goes the council should
be able to react to the current threats
and challenges therefore we need the
reformed Security Council to remain
relatively small and compact in general
we support the expansion of the
representation of the Security Council
in the countries of Africa in Latin
America we do not doubt that these group
of countries have many of those who can
make the series contribution to the
support of international peace and
security
we do not hide that we're skeptical of
the idea of limiting the vital right we
consider it as an important element in
working out balanced and verify
decisions of the council and supporting
the interests of the minorities it is no
secret for anyone that many have seen
this recently in the West they can
mobilize enough votes in the Security
Council required to block the unwanted
projects without using the right of veto
at the same time the methods of this
mobilization are far from the relative
far from the norms and regulations of
the UN Charter Russia gradually follows
the harmonizing of the system of
international relations thus the
principles and the political decisions
should be taken and refusal from wildin
change of the regime commitment to this
principle
the basis against the policy of its
rights so there were a lots of there
were many questions regarding and/or
speaking now the situation that we after
the analysis we will definitely comment
on that after adoption of the Louis on
fighting the manipulation of information
in France as you know on the 20th of
February the back of as it was called by
French expert Oh of fighting the
manipulation or with information they
were approved contrary to the Senate's
decision which were against Parliament
and regardless of the critical
estimations of the opposition parts and
journalists and experts including Lamont
and Figaro according to the adopted law
the French Supreme Council on
audio-visual means his the authority in
the period from 3 starting from 3 months
before the national elections to take
the decision on season the operation of
the mass media spread in the fake news
in digital platforms also have must take
measures to counter spreading of this
information in the internet and any
early provide report to the council on
the work they've done for many times we
have underlined the discriminatory
character of these legislative
initiatives to clear information
environment from their points of view
which are not comfortable for those who
are at the levers of taking the decision
to the provisions of these law at the
same time we have no doubt that the
French authorities have a goal to create
legal ground - yeah effect Russian the
media is speaking about foreign media
which the rights have been what the
rights of which have been violated for
quite long I don't want to remind once
more not going too deep into the history
perfectly noting where it really comes
from and how it all began I would like
to remind you about the events of the
here the employees of Sputnik and Russia
today cannot get obtained press cards
necessary to perform journalist activity
in the country to attend official events
which are held in governmental premises
the policy of discrimination is well
known the policy I'm speaking about and
it is accompanied by announcements of
the French officials disturbing
announcements which mainly are the
initiators usually are the initiators of
this fake information blaming them that
today this German media which is not
really to blame for quite a fresh
example of that the information referred
to directly of Federal anti-monopoly
service with the representatives of the
media and us as journalists wanted to
like they manually were not let you
attend the conference of mr. Lavrov in
Paris it's like it's violation of
freedom of speech and the
representatives of the media from two
fronts both legislative and like
manually menu mode we expect that it
will be reconsidered by the profile
structures protecting the equal access
to information and freedom of
information speech and in meetings of on
the sidelines of the upcoming mission of
ministers Foreign Affairs we will have
this topic discussed I would also like
to say that it's hard for me to imagine
how angry our French colleagues would be
if anything say similar would be made in
the Russian Federation or
aimed at the French journalists in
Russia I'm speaking about fake
information and how it is fought in the
world in the neighboring country with
France Great Britain been marked with
interior rugs Russian rhetorics
information around brexit an ability to
find consensus in the society on this
issue all that forces the authorities to
find some distraction maneuvers and what
can be better in this case than another
foreign outer threat and the source is
not hard to find it's Russia definitely
this plot has been worked through quite
long ago so one day before the summit of
European Council on brexit on 24th of
November head of the headquarters great
in Great Britain
mr. Otto Smith's EF interview totally
terror Telegraph where Russia was
represented as a major bigger threat to
the national security than al-qaeda and
Isis this is quite significant blame
bearing in mind that we still perfectly
remember the terror the terrorist
attacks and Great Britain in London in
Manchester and creation of big hello
fought in the Middle East
was possible to prevent thanks to
involvement of Russian steel Russia is
the main threat in the view of one of
the major military people in the Great
Britain and in the avant-garde of in the
frontlines of Russian phobic information
is this definitely it's definitely this
story with a so-called poisonous
family think it's hard to understand
what happened actually it seems that the
acuteness of this situation was started
to go down still there was nothing to
discuss in the city and there's nothing
to remain to be discussed in this
situation but as you all could see this
approach has not become a priority one
has not had any developments and it
begin all over again on 22nd of November
the in prime time there was a
sensational investigation like a movie
which was prepared by journalists I
think that each and every one has to
make his own opinion about this movie
about this film I think it's a must it
must see for everybody and user number
of reasons in this film an attempt is
obvious to develop the chronology of the
events to reconstruct the alleged events
but country to the idea line where the
wish of author is following many facts
which are gathered in the film I'll give
an absolutely country effect opposite
effect because there is similarly do not
match an official British version
definitely there is an emotional
component which is also interesting the
offers are
trying to use classical Hollywood tricks
like mysterious music following the
narrative and if Salisbury is
demonstrated as a quiet lovely town with
peaceful green grass and peaceful
landscape animals all around people are
living calmly and nicely that Moscow is
being demonstrated as dark Wicked's
threatening evil center of the evil is
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs you can
secure your children with that that's
how this building is demonstrated
well obviously the main hero should be I
should have been found in this movie and
both as you and I were expected the main
hero Rahman personality should be either
the victim the victim or the crime
criminal the a legit criminal that
basically that's the film logic
classical film logic but no it wasn't
like that yes you got the destiny of
Nick Bailey is in the core of the field
who alledgedly was poisoned by that
that's the only person by the poisoning
component he's the only person who who
can be presented to the world you can
basically touch him and answer ask for
some answers he can do it others are not
available the authors were pointing at a
person who was risking his life
performing his duty who was deprived of
all his property but the elementary
question is that nobody cared why there
was no compensation if there was no
compensation that's a question to the
authority if it was well it at least he
was paid back for that but these are
just minor things I have no answer wife
out of three policemen which were
investigating the house only one person
suffered only one police
policeman suffered others will not
mention what happened to them I don't
really know so these questions not they
deriving from the idea to find some
false some mistakes just arrived being
around being asked during the movie they
are quite numerous and generally the
film is quite a success like the tea was
perfect but they didn't put C in the
boiling water the Queen the main issue
is still open aware are this grip strip
Al's family are they alive are they in
Great Britain or they were taking
somewhere what is their condition are
they together
or they are separated who is working
with them and using worth working I'm
using deliberately this word because
with such people
even before the incidents the British
people were working with them and after
the so called poisoning they are the
groups of experts working in all the
dimensions where are these people who
are together with repulse and in a
script our family now and calm
cooperation with them somehow why the
law enforcement was ready to assist
journalist journalists in all sphere
while preparing this film except for
access to sleep by the family if the mi
see mr. Soros head of mi6 who was the
permanent representative serve in the
Security Council of the UN says that he
has the information he gives a hint like
he allegedly has the information about
where scribbled family is why this
person knows more than the public I
don't know them Russia knows I don't
know because Julia's is a
citizen of Russia still minutes after
minute the events of 4th of March
recreated and later on with all the
steps
obviously Petrov and Bashir of the
reaction of police up to cooperation
with the laboratory of Porton Down
still we have a question and how do they
feel scribble-scribble family what they
were doing
Julia was seen at least once in Great
Britain by a British on British TV well
Julia could have said what happened to
her this day at least what she remembers
some may be feeling some may be memories
or something at least something why
everything had to be started from
Lincoln to people which you cannot prove
to be part of this incident and making
like the central essential pictures of
the film though there is at least one
real personality of this drama Julia's
creepy who is a life and could have said
a told about what happens she was there
at least we were told that that all this
chronology is developed up to the moment
of cooperation with the Porton Down
Laboratory still there is a gap there is
a question of movements of this group
our family themselves from their
previous messages was said that they
left house and 9:30 a going through the
north-east if we watch the map north
east is important down direction like a
coincidence they switched off their cell
phones and after that they like came out
of the house once more at half-past one
where they were going why did they come
back who were the people they were
meeting when they got back home why
these issues of interest for the Russian
side but not for the journalists who
were preparing this film and not for a
week or two going forward the police
examined as we know it and as it has
been said previously eleven thousands of
footage from the CCTV in Salisbury and
whereas is crippled family there
eleven thousand hours of CCTV footage
the record there is a record with the
trophy but sheriff and the sheriff how
these people what they were doing in the
town in the context of the convictions
which were announced is not clear but we
are asked repulse family footage just
anybody believe that the former agent of
the British intelligence who was
returned to the Great Britain was
located there and was not followed by
the authorities by the British
authorities that somebody believed it of
course not and their house was
surrounded by many many video
surveillance cameras and the cameras of
the intelligence so where is this
footage when they were speaking about
the substance which was allegedly used
for poisoning we have even more
questions in the movie it was said that
the investigation was immediately
immediately found out that it was
applied on the knob of the entrance door
to the house how about the versions
which were repeatedly published by the
British media and the BBC other versions
then maybe some apologies had to be
announced has had to be made that yes
everything you see in the film
contradicts the information which we
were spread and we do not want to be a
fake TV channel and we say that the
previous Russians are not true
or at least mildly down that were not
proven I remember that during one of
briefings we were accumulating all of
this versions of the British media and
dozens of these versions were found why
these journalists do not find ask
question why everybody was confused
about that or they were elderly confused
and was it manipulate and attempt to
manipulate people
[Music]
and it's I'm sorry to say that's this
material was prepared while this
material was prepared inside Porton Down
and outside Portland down events were
not considered we was focusing a lot of
attention to that and still this
journalists do not ask questions about
the activity of development of Navy
chalk in the laboratory some mistakes
and the details about the
characteristics of the substance the
Soviet chemist mr. Yan of interview said
that Navy chalk is easily decomposed
with the contact world water but weather
was not that was moist in that day
that's why script parts were not fatally
poisoned if they were not let's start
from the very beginning if they were not
poisoned fatally how can you say they
are life and if their life they are not
demonstrated why they are not
demonstrated at least in this movie this
film if the thing is like it is declared
in this film and it's all about British
rainy weather why there was a
large-scale there is infection made by
the authorities why they were using
strong ingredients why they were
demolishing houses where's cripples were
in and that day maybe it was just to
wash it with water the material would
decompose and that's it or it was an
operation to get rid of something else
like other chemical elements why the
British journalist did not pay their
attention to that in this case another
experts which is quoted in the film
professor Tim from Porton Down and in
this film the names were fake but still
the faces were not hidden I don't know
maybe these are also actors nobody says
about that he
was assuring that this of the volumes
which were used of this substance could
have destroyed thousands of people who
have killed thousands of people why just
a few people suffered the house of
scribble escape al is not located in the
downtown but it's not it's not in the
outskirts it's not like in the in the
void they were neighboring dwelling
premises
especially worth machines and not a
number of some movie tricks like trance
translation of the relatives of us
cripples announcer who was speaking
English with a strong Russian accent
like guys well where do we live if you
make a translation from Russian into
English and for no reason a person who
knows who English language
professionally and speaking professional
is trying to speak with his accent like
for the people to feel something else
they have to feel deliberately that is
trying to change his voice liberally for
the people to have like full submersion
in the situation and of course la créme
de la créme it's from the best seller
offers une about the demonstration in
the future to the future participants of
such dramas what can happen to them like
a film of like burning treasure of the
mother Lance's which was represented by
CIA you know is like fairy tales
basically that's an absurd thing that's
not some nonsense which is demonstrated
as a typical journalists attempt in
journalists work actually this work has
been done but it was done the way that
it did not answer the question in the
materials which were provided aroused
even more
it all happens in the country which is
in geographical vicinity with France
where laws on fake news is located I am
really surprised with that one one issue
with the freedom of information last
week when police were arrested you Dalek
CF who is the head of internet portal
and one of the leaders of public
organization of non-citizens Congrats
I remember that it is protected the
structure is protecting non-citizens and
information in in the country so
according to the lawyer of the
journalist he was arrested with a
certain means of violence after that he
was mentally and psychologically
suppressed the journalist was criminally
followed in December then some bullets
were brought to him from a pistol these
are actual actual repressions - towards
this journalist an attempt to make him
silent such examples
unfortunately in latvia are the common
practice to suppress the alternative
meanings they could keep fighting with
the russian speaking in public
personalities using actual falsification
in criminal pressing with we think that
this should not be left untouched and we
call the international organisations
they always see comments comments from
brussels how these activities go in line
with general or with common European
democratic values on the 3rd of December
the Russia celebrates their unknown
soldiers day when we
commemorate the Fallen sons of our
motherland this date was established
quite recently in 2014 this was the day
when in 1966 in the commemoration of a
victory on the Nazis the remains of a
known soldier was brought to the
monument in Alexander sickie garden next
to the Moscow Kremlin annually our
representatives abroad with close
cooperation with the CIA s F commemorate
our commemorates in that this is an
important tradition in order to preserve
the memory and it has developed
worldwide from China to the European
countries to the US and Canada more
precise a story about issue that's you
can find on the electronic resources of
our embassies today I'd like to focus on
the ceremony opening of the memorial
memorials were the names of almost 2,500
Russian military and prisoners which
died in imprisoned and were buried in
the central the central cemetery of
sokoloff in Czech Republic for the first
time such a big number were of Russian
warriors war commemorated directly in
the place where they were buried these
names returned from the fog of history
as a result of thorough work of
categorization which was performed by
the representatives of the Ministry of
Defense of Russian Federation with the
support of General Council in catalogue
of our embassies etc the representative
office employees examined over 25,000
cards of the those in prisons they
managed to find over 2,000 people who
were missing the ceremony which was are
organized
by the administration we expect that we
will provide information support to that
obviously participation we're speaking
about participation of the
representatives of Russia and the CIS
countries relatives of those fallen
soldiers and this day will be of special
importance for them the fact that this
initiative was implemented in practice
is especially important on the
background of the recent events of our
briefings we regularly refer to the
topic of cynical actions of destruction
of the memorials of Soviet soldiers in
the Eastern Europe and fortunately
Poland has is on top in this list where
such events are held with a silent
agreement with the local authorities or
even participation of them these are not
single cases like acts of spontaneous
vandalism it's a tendency the last
briefing was asked about Russian
position on the general framework dates
on agreement in bosnian gets a given
peace for peace 23 years have passed
after the Dayton Agreement was signed as
you remember that mr. dodyk has become
the chair of the Presidium of boston
years ago he said that he will be aimed
at elimination of the apparatus of
supreme representative I was asked
whether Russia is ready for that our
position has changed I have to say in
this region due to the questions we mr.
the Minister of Foreign Affairs has
focused on that and
broadly answering this question I wanted
to say that Russian Federation has is
gradually following the general
framework agreement on of 1994 the basic
principles which explained as respect to
sovereignty and territorial territorial
integrity of the country nor to anti
deaths
rid the Republic of Serbian Federation
big and equal rights of three
constitutional peoples there this
reproach approaches our devices are
supported by the whole parties in the
region what was proven by during the
working trip of Minister of Foreign
Affairs to Sir Ivan Daniel Luke 120 of
on 21st of September Russia as an active
participant ins of stabilization process
in the region and in tireli on the
platform of the Security Council and the
Committee on performing the peaceful
agreements we are continues to go into
in line with information and we have
announced many times that we approve of
removing of the apparatus of supreme
representative we derived from the idea
that this protectorate presence has run
out of resource and blocks the normal
development of the state as a sovereign
independent country we canvassed and
convinced that successful functioning of
the country is capable is possible only
over the use of balanced States on
agreements implementation oriented on
individual of fighting the consensus on
all the issues we think that the role of
international community communities
should be limited to contributes into
the Boston people and
this approach absolutely reflects the
support of the peoples in order to
stabilize the situation in the Balkans
and I have also received a question last
time you're here a question regarding
the Ottawa Convention problem Russia
shares the tasks and goals of the
Convention prohibiting anti-personnel
landmines Ottawa Convention is being
implemented within the Convention on
inhumane weapons and its supplementary
protocol number two how approach the
countering the mine threat known and we
take active efforts in the creation of
the world free of mines in recent years
Russia has cleared over ten million
mines including anti-personnel mines
since 1994 our country has had a ban on
the transfer of an locatable and
personnel land mines as well as the
mines that do not have a self-destruct
mechanism keeping in mind the
humanitarian aspects of this problem
since 1998 the production of
anti-personnel high-explosive mines was
fully stopped they are one of the main
sources of victims among the civilians
the Defense Ministry of Russia in 2001
released a recommendation on the
international humanitarian law for our
armed forces that defines the main
requirements to the use of
anti-personnel mines in accordance with
the supplementary protocol the
engineering forces of the Russian
Federation have accumulated a large
technical and scientific and expert
potential that allows us to take part in
mine clearance operations of any
difficulty at different times the
Russian Armed Forces took part in
operations of mine clearance in Bosnia
Herzegovina Croatia Kosovo region
Nicaragua Serbia since December 2016 the
Russian military has held a mine
clearing operations on the territory of
Syria exactly - in the localities of
merav Palmyra and one operation in
Aleppo and Deir al-zor
currently we're carrying out work in
south ossetia an important role in the
russian mine clearance activities is
given to the 2014 established
international my anti mine center of the
russian armed forces it provides
training for specialists in locating and
disarming mines land clearance and
working on technical complexes and
systems we emphasize the openness of
this structure to international
cooperation and its eagerness and
readiness to share its expertise with
all the interested parties in countries
in order to use the accumulated
experience of human hair and mine
clearance Russia takes efforts in
registering in the center at the UN
project management center to include it
into the subsidiary organizations
carrying out Unitarian mine clearance
operations under the auspices on the UN
of the commercial basis as well as
registering in the peacekeeping
potential system of the United Nations
and the same time we draw your attention
to the fact that landmines remain cost
efficient means of providing in security
of our borders based on the defense
interests of our country adhering to the
document is currently not recommended I
would also like to know that the
countries that do not share the idea of
a full ban on anti-personnel mines are
rather significant group that includes
the leading manufacturers and users of
such mines
I mean Israel India China Pakistan the
United States the document does not
involve such countries as Azerbaijan
Armenia vietname gypped Iran Kazakhstan
China Cuba Mongolia the United Arab
Emirates Saudi Arabia Syria Singapore
Pakistan South Korea and others and now
I'm ready to answer your questions if
you have any yes please
yes you an asana Omaha Baku Information
Agency is sorry Gann recently they had
of the circle claim nagorno-karabakh
Republic Mississauga ON visited Moscow
and the Azerbaijani foreign ministry
said that the entry permit through the
Russian Federation for this leader
undermined the efforts of the peace
process on nagorno-karabakh settlement
and in general contradicted the Russian
obligations has the co-chair of the
Minsk Group of the OSCE could you
clarify the position of the Russian
Foreign Ministry on the visit of zaqqum
to Moscow you know this visit cannot be
considered and in any other way than
private it status is apparent it does
not go against the Russian law and this
is exactly how it was this was a private
trip that does not contradict any
international obligations of Russia
Indian and the Goron Karabakh settlement
that's why the protest to Russia
expressed in the recent declaration of
Azerbaijan in our view groundless yes
please
Rahman coaster of Russia today
Washington has warned Russia exactly
Pentagon called in Russia to stop
falsifying the facts of the alleged
chemical attack carried out on Saturday
in Aleppo in Syria what do you think
about such warnings and do they have any
reasons to suppose that Russia could
somehow block the investigation this is
an absurd claim unfortunately it goes in
the line of many other absurd claims and
suppositions of our American colleagues
I've just made a comment on this topic
let me say that the OPCW must carry out
objective impartial analysis and
investigation of these events that is
why I think
that our us colleagues perhaps do not
keep an eye on the statements of the
Russian authorities and officials in
particular Russian diplomats perhaps
they should take a look at our website
yes please German Orlov federal news
agency about an hour ago we received
news that the president of Ukraine Petro
poroshenko banned entry to Ukraine to
Russian citizens male citizens aged from
16 to 60 years old
how will the Foreign Ministry react and
should we await mirror measures you know
as for Ukraine and most importantly not
exactly the state but the regime that is
currently installed in power
speaking of mirror measures would be
very scary because if anyone tried to do
the same and to mirror the things that
currently happened in Kiev this could
result in full madness if we talk about
the national scale this would result in
collapse the events the actions that we
see in Kiev and in general in Ukraine
this is a manifestation of the
dysfunctional government and
dysfunctional statehood which is a
result of wild exactly while actions by
the country's authorities as for this
decision I think it goes in the line of
what has just been said yes please
Tass Information Agency have the
Ukrainian diplomats expressed an
intention to visit Ukrainian citizens I
mean those arrested crews after the
provocation incurred straight
thank you Ukraine has sent a note asking
for consular access
- they're detained citizens I must say
that this always happens when we deal
with such serious arrests and detentions
which are covered in the mass media in
other cases the Ukrainian diplomats
generally do not show any eagerness as
for the answer to your question yes we
have received this note yes please hello
here is mine if International Life
magazine Georgia has had international
presidential elections won by selma is
rubbish fille we know that this is a
diplomat with great experience from
ambassador and the georgian foreign
minister the russian foreign minister
had any affairs with this person in the
past and what do you expect from this
choice of the georgian people you know
you must not know the answer to this
question because you said yourself that
yes he used to be a foreign minister of
georgia and is well known on that post
as for our expectations this is not a
question - the foreign ministry we
adhere to our position which is well
known to all of you in the position
other states russia did not initiate the
cut of diplomatic links with georgia we
think this was a great and grave mistake
made by the Georgian authorities at that
time we understand that the peoples of
our - of States suffer from this state
of affairs and in different areas which
unfortunately are not linked with
interstate communications for example
culture economy humanitarian links the
relations continue between our people
but they are very aggravated by the lack
of normal official diplomatic ties
between the our states
yes please understand 24 what does the
Russian Foreign Ministry think about the
relations between Raqqa Kurdistan and
Baghdad and how can Russia promote the
settlement or rather improving the
relations between these sites still as
had been said previously we think Iraq
is an integral state of course we
develop our relations with Baghdad at
the same time you know we have economic
links and energy cooperation with the
regions of Iraq on the basis of
respecting the main principle the
principle of interstate relations and
links as for our possible contribution
to the improvement of dialogue I think
that first due to the practice of Russia
Iraq relations the theory comes up in
theory and in practice we can say that
dialogue and mutual respect are needed
and we must make sure that this concept
is implemented in practice yes please
thank you very much Dida press
unfortunately yesterday we found out
that g20 will not host the
russian-american dialogue and Mike
Pompeo said that he had no plans of
meeting Sergey Lavrov
unfortunately the INF dialogue is also
slowing down in your opinion due to this
decision of the United States what will
be the further development of the Russia
US relations and what will happen to the
INF treaty as for the future agreement
recently we had a briefing by the deputy
foreign minister of the Russian
Federation mr. ripped off and frankly
speaking I have nothing to add
I could only address you to the
transcript of that briefing it is
available on our website
Emrys pages cover this topic in great
detail and in a professional way as for
the future of our bilateral relations
we've been talking for a long
time that we should break the stalemate
and this events in Washington rather
hard to analyze if we talk about the
daily day-to-day strategy of the
political elites there since the
strategies changed by the minute and by
the second speaking globally everything
is clear we are witnessing a real harsh
internal political struggle results of
which is the aggravation of relations
between the United States of America
with various countries of the world not
only countries but also organizations
international agreements and so on this
is one of the results of this internal
struggle yes please
continuing the topic of the g20 summit
as you know in the first of December
Shinzo Abe a will meet the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and Japan has
very high expectations of the continued
talks on the peaceful peace agreement
based on 1956 declaration and as a
result subsequently exact agreements
with the Russian Federation do we have
similar expectations you know we can
repeat again and again the topical
phrases on our expectations and how to
stimulate them by adding words on the
national issues and beat around the bush
but we have the exact action plans that
can be implemented in order to have real
movement and our Japanese partners and
you all know this since this so-called
plan or rather pattern of actions is
well known we are not hiding anything
that's why we expectations are great
diplomatic actions wonderful we use
every opportunity and we are grateful
for similar approaches from Japan as you
know recently there was another meeting
in between the Russian Foreign Minister
with his Japanese counterpart but if we
talk about any movement
and progress the meeting and the contact
is fine but still we need to implement
what had been agreed upon yes please
Marie sons of Bulgaria media most I have
three questions if I make the first
question yesterday Prime Minister
Bulgarian Morocco declared that Russian
president is not one to be joked with
and along with the Bulgarian president
he called on the liberation of the shape
seized in the courage straight although
it's hard to call them ships I do not
agree I think the Russian authorities
have a great sense of humor but another
thing is that we should not be provoked
that's a fact and continuing this
question what Marissa said that a new
gas natural gas hab construction is
expected to endure could Bulgaria become
a new natural gas transit hub Maurice
[Music]
are you the one asking this question can
Bulgaria take part in the natural gas
agreements Bulgaria had such chances for
many years and Bulgaria itself denied
that but the process continues then you
should not ask about the chances
everyone has a chance but all the states
using these chances or not and the third
question recently the former prime
minister of Macedonia received a rest
warrant did he apply for political
asylum in Russia and are you planning to
visit the Republic of Macedonia are you
I personally you know as for the request
for political asylum you said I do not
have such information I will get back to
you later perhaps but I do not hear
anything of the sorts as for my plans to
visit Macedonia well if there's a reason
I will be glad to do so thank you
yes please iced tea of Caucasus
Information Agency the turkish President
Erdogan said that Ankara was there ready
to become immediate intermediator in the
car straight incident we've said similar
statements from our partners in Germany
and other countries and I think Russia
has already said that in this case we're
not talking about intermediary efforts
we say that we need to make sure Kiev
acts in line we need to make sure it
comes in line with the politicians that
have been encouraging it for the recent
years and the things that we see now
were fabricated this is the result what
Ukrainian the world have seen after
experiments on democracy and statehood
conducted by our Western colleagues the
United States of America and of course
the European structures as well as
certain states of the European continent
I think that now it is time to take
responsibility and let us be closer to
reality and with no sarcasm
we can say that Ukraine needs real help
because under its current leadership if
we can see so under the current
president it is too far from
provocations yes please
Oleg Bhagat area of national course
Information Agency we are concerned
about the growing degree of extremism
against the diplomatic agencies
diplomats in Ukraine and if this degree
keeps growing and rising is there a
chance of moving certain diplomatic
functions from Kiev from both for
example to Donbass to donetsk and
lughansk
in order to support the legitimacy of
Donbass as a territory of Ukraine that
did not support the military coup of
2014 and this is also a matter of the
diplomat security and thirdly this would
mean support for the political project
of malorossiya left by Alexander
zaharchenko that's a long question a
very multifaceted let me concentrate on
the main essence of diplomatic missions
I will say that keeping in mind that the
media regularly cover the facts that
Ukrainian radicals threatened Russian
diplomatic and consular missions and
this is always covered with video
footage and this is not done on federal
channels deliberately these footage is
available on the internet on social
media there is a great amount of photos
and videos to people send them and share
them
I have only have one question does
Ukraine itself understand that at one
point the Russian public could lose its
patience let me remind you that the
Ukrainian diplomatic corps and
implementing missions in Russia are
present here we support contacts with
the Ukrainian diplomats in Moscow and
other cities we respect them and protect
them but the issue is that we all are
real and we understand that people for
example sometimes express their
indignation there is a limit to any
patience and I'm afraid that new
provocations against the Russian
diplomatic sites in Ukraine by radicals
could become the tipping point these are
not ordinary Ukrainians this is not the
general population that works so to earn
his bread the working people do not have
the time to go in break our property
they try to earn for their living in the
current difficult conditions to provide
for their families and simply to survive
they will not go out on the streets and
spend hours throwing stones and the
Molotov cocktails at our diplomatic
missions and burn down the cars these
people are either paid or their natural
nationalists perhaps in their training
or in their nature but this is only one
of the thousands of questions and the
demands to stop this tyranny that we'd
receive on a daily basis and the
Ministry and I think Ukraine must
understand this of course officially
Moscow will do everything in order to
remain adherent to all the diplomatic
relation conventions and protect the
diplomatic structures of Ukraine in the
territory of our country but there is a
limit to the patience of our people
remember this and a certain point on
your question whether we considered
moving our embassies and missions you
know we have a recent example in history
sometimes the transfer is not required
sometimes the diplomatic status changes
for example we used to have a Consulate
General in Simferopol then it became the
mission of the foreign ministry in the
region of Russia this happens yes please
good afternoon
first of all let me thank you for
answering my previous question during
the briefing concerning Pakistan and the
attack on the consulate of China I would
like to know how can we understand the
double standards in Great Britain they
provide for one side and support a
leader of a terrorist organization and
host him on the other hand
they H ampion for Human Rights and
declare that they not interfere in other
Affairs and they've done this in an
example of Russia how can we understand
these double standards
you know I've partially answered we do
not have the information on the
representative of that organization
extremist organization that you
mentioned is currently on the territory
of the United Kingdom if you have the
fact that you can prove this and if you
receive the official British position on
this topic then we would be more than
glad to make our own political
declaration as of today we cannot make a
comment on the presence of the person
since we lacked the information as
you've said we have certain differences
from Britain and we do not do
speculations for the lack of information
but if you give us this information we
will analyze it yes please say they have
German television electron off in the
beginning you said that Minister Lavrov
was coming to Milan next week to take
part in the Ministerial Council of the
OSCE will he have a meeting we on the
sidelines with minister klimkin of
ukraine and if yes what could be the
topic the Ukrainian minister klimkin yes
he is also a member of the OSC you know
the minister's agenda is currently being
worked on currently he is in Argentina
as a member of the presidential
delegation and g20 and he might also
have contacts with the heads of foreign
policies and foreign ministries I think
in the beginning of next week we will
have information for you
on the upcoming meetings the milano
platform of the OSC we we're currently
working on it and the exact information
will be available later yes please
my dream glasses vest a TV channel if I
may to questions the first one
concerning the declarations of threesome
a last night saying that the incident
incurred straight means they need for
new sanctions against Russia
how could you comment on this and the
second question concern well you've
already mentioned the russian-american
relations at the summit and could you
comment would it be reasonable for the
US delegation to cancel the meeting with
President Putin less than a day in
advance would it be reasonable so good
work in the context of this topic you
know answering the first question saying
that last night and miss Mei said that
the Kerch situation was a reason to
impose new sanctions against Russia we
can come down and not mention any
protects they do not need the pretexts
we all know too well that Britain as
well as the number of political
officials in the West have a clear
position of sanction pressure both
against Russia and other states
therefore they think it is possible to
settle and solve their own problems or
somehow influence the International
agenda this is their approach so what is
the point of talking about the Kerch
incident or the Syrian settlement or
other regions this is all redundant I
think it would be better and more honest
and it would be easier just say that new
sanctions are needed against Russia
that's it and I think who no one will
have any questions to her we're just
repeating the mantra yeah the words are
changing but the dance remains the same
as for your second question on
whether it's reasonable or not I think
this is a question that should be
related to all the American political
scientists who know the internal
political situation in the country so
the word reason rather speaks about the
internal agenda we're talking about
solving exact issues we're talking about
the future of the INF treaty and the
issues of global agenda and from this
point of view any contact and especially
contact at the level of heads of states
that had been announced in advance and
that was preceded by serious preparation
work this would be progress but as for
reason and reason ability please address
this question to the American Society
good-afternoon inform against that
agency trend in the beginning of the
briefing you said that the head of the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs Sergey
Lavrov at the session of the Council of
the ministers of Foreign Affairs of the
OEC is planning to speak about the
settlement of Nagoya and got a buck
visit planned to discuss on further
steps of the ways out of the conflict
you know this speech of the minister
we're speaking about the speech of the
ministry at the session it will cover
everything which is in the agenda of the
OSC in particular in the issues we where
Russia is directly involved we will
share our estimations definitely there
will be bilateral meetings I have
referred to previously and during that
meetings this problem this issue will be
discussed more thoroughly in a more
practical manner
there are definitely some specific steps
can be appointed to some proposals
radio likes to finally find out about
the refusal of Trump to meet Putin on
the basis of cashier incidents do you
think is it interconnected and who will
meet Putin instead of Trump in Bern
Cyrus and about the possibility and
contracts of the United States the
contracts of the obligations of the
United States what they suffer in that
way like postponing is the typical fresh
in u.s. relations
Trump is an absolutely new thing for
many in many cases he is innovative in
many spheres if we're speaking of your
first question was his courage provoke a
provocation and catch which was made by
Kia for real reason for canceling the
meeting officially we heard that is it a
reality I think we have to ask for
answers in the home policy home
political situation in the US I think
this is the dominant reason the inside
situation has a home policy situation in
the United States the political
situation inside the United States was
it decided prior to that so after that I
cannot say but everything what is
happening in the bilateral relations of
the recent few years it's something
really outstanding he started from Obama
Obama was the first to do it and
unfortunately is going on
decrees in bilateral relations was a
deliberate choice of Obama's president
and his team unilateral deliberate
choice of path for a decrease in the in
their relations what we have now I think
that's the first of all that's the
heritage of the course which was taken
previously which cannot disappear right
away secondly this is that very
reflection of the political struggle
which we see inside the United States I
think would has already been displayed
deployed but it's now an extent expand
the schedule of the president is
committed by the president's
administration do you have any any other
questions yes please
there's no no no for Matson against a
news from book Bulgarian Office of news
france maria vladimirovna the issue is
referred to information war the sentence
of the US has taken unanimously the
resolution on Russia's fault and
aggression against the Ukraine in
connection with the provocation and cash
trace I am not quite in front of
informed about that maybe you know with
when a journalist was missing and after
that was killed and was working for the
American and the smear the Senate has
figured it out or did they have
something there they are not interested
okay and in the resolution of the Senate
it's calls for the members of the
international community to unite in
opposition to the authorities of the
government of the Russian Federation and
catch straight because they violated
their founding principles of the
international legislation and
international law influence in all the
countries is this resolution called to
put extra pressure in other countries
and this resolution is a show in
extremely low educational level of those
who were creating this resolution these
are people who have no idea about the
things they are speaking about they do
not know the real
context they do not understand and do
not see the details in the problems
which they comment on in this serious
manner I would like to repeat once more
this is the United States and these are
the United States and the political
establishment there are is responsible
for the fate of Ukraine and direct
supervision of the representatives of
States Department of the US and my dance
happens turnovers disperse of the
legitimately elected structures and all
those changes which we are observing
under the supervision of the US
diplomats representatives of law
enforcement secret services the future
of Ukraine was planned the state
authorities information policy was
formed and the policy obviously on
Dumba's so instead of adopting another
paper I think they have to understand
the role of their country and their
officials in the tragedy in Ukraine and
to make some a different announcement
for example like on the role of State
Department of the US in 2013 and 2014 in
the events which took place in Ukraine
yes please Armenia on the 6th of
December in st. Petersburg the
[Music]
discussion of the General Secretariat
CSC in the CSTO and the Romanian
representative can be there in the
similar office now appointed for this
position
are there any consultations between the
two parties of the new general
secretary-general and what how they are
going they are not it has not been
consulted only between
exclusively between Armenian and Russian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs this
discussion is held between all the CSTO
member-states I think it requires no
clarification why because we're speaking
about the leadership of the mmm
organization where the relative
countries the related countries are part
of s4 the options you have said about
this is a responsibility of experts it
has to be worked through by the experts
and the decision has to be taken by the
leadership of the countries this is the
issue of the decision should that should
be taken basing on the expert analysis
at this the moment I do not have any
more specific information if this is if
any normal questions are here I will
allow myself to wish everybody to have
really good weekends without politics as
it is Friday today one issue on the OSC
as far as I understand them can be a
meeting of our often Karabakh conflict
is there a planning plan to Karabakh to
hold it that's why I took time to Montee
because yesterday we were there was a
return from Geneva quite lately and now
the minister is in Argentina and now the
schedule has been elaborated I took time
to figure it out and on Monday we will
do thank you thank you
[Applause]